so i don't know what you guys think but
i think i just got a new team of makeup
artists
one thing we know about the kardashians
this family loves a makeover
i'm focused on work and like taking care
of me my body and soul on wednesday
chloe shared her latest makeup look
courtesy of daughter true kylie's
daughter stormi
kim's daughter chicago and rob's
daughter dream
[Music]
oh my gosh what are you doing to me
no don't do that to my phone where her
babysitting gig came with a surprise
makeover dreamy what are you guys doing
to me
but chloe expressed her appreciation for
this up-and-coming glam squad
so i don't know what you guys think but
i think i just got a new
team of makeup artists true and dream
stormy and shy
killed it while rob didn't share his
activities that day
let's check in on what the moms were up
to chloe and i have a really good thing
going on right now
shy's brothers som and saint volunteered
to spot mom
kim during her workout kim wrote little
visitors in the gym today
vampire meanwhile we saw kylie using her
free time to catch up on one of her
favorites
sharing this twilight pov to her
instagram story
she captioned the video couldn't be
happier i mean
i think that there's you know one day
we'll all be working for stormy too
probably so
and stormi's latest makeover endeavor
follows last week's showcase of her
mom's
beauty empire where the three-year-old
gave a tour of her very own
office at kylie cosmetics headquarters
kylie goes to work
with stormy and stormy loves it she just
you know absorbs it this is where you
get to hang out when you come to work
the video is part of kylie's youtube
series which takes fans inside her
billion dollar company
but the highlight of these sneak peeks
has to be stormy's love of the office
candy
oh okay get out of here
get out of here
you